ludovic rochette canton de dijon iv
c'est le vôtre vous êtes en deuxième
position après ce premier tour avec 180
voix de retard sur le binôme de gauche
le front national n'accède pas au
deuxième tour en gros il ya 1200 voix du
front national sur la table quelle est
votre position à vous après ce premier
tour 1 par rapport aux électeurs qui ont
fait le choix du front national ou dans
cette élection il ya un autre facteur
aussi c'est l'abstention
en ce qu on est sur un électeur sur deux
qui c'est qui s'est déplacé aujourd'hui
et je pense déjà à eux a eu qui doit
venir le 29 mars prochain pour montrer
qu'ils feront de vous faire confiance à
mr chasse et moi même et puis ben
concernant la campagne on a eu quand
même à faire à des candidats fantômes
des candidats fn seront pourtant je peux
vous dire ce soit des candidats fantômes
et je veux bien distinguer ce qui est du
fn et de leur candidat et et l'électorat
parce que bien sûr que je pense que et
fut vous aussi sur notre canton
on a rencontré de la colère on a montré
des attentes et ce résultat-là me
surprendre pas beaucoup je suis
d'ailleurs très content de ce résultat
sur le canton du jour 4 parce qu'on en
situation de gagner ce canton dijon 4
alors que le découpage au départ
n'étaient pas faits dans ce sens donc
notre résultat est vraiment positif